[Musique]
claude blanche raison bonjour heureux de
vous retrouver dans la matinale de rtl
france alors pourquoi vladimir poutine
at-il convoqué les deux dirigeants à
moscou écoutez nous sommes deux mois
après la négociation du cessez le feu
le/la carrasso tripartite du 10 novembre
2020 et je crois qu'il était en effet
important de faire le point le
cessez-le-feu est maintenant respecter
et il ya eu pas mal d'entorse en cours
de route mais aujourd'hui on peut
considérer que le cessez le feu est
respecté que le contrôle des territoires
qui étaient prévues par ce cessez-le-feu
a été établi naturellement avec la
présence de la force de maintien de la
paix de la de la russie un peu moins de
2000 hommes sont sur place et que
monsieur poutine a dit aussi que 48
mille réfugiés d'arménie arméniens sont
revenus au nid grandi karabakh
par conséquent ce premier volet de
l'accord de cessez-le-feu semble être
appliquée et il était question hier
surtout d'organiser la deuxième phase la
deuxième phase est très importante
puisque c'est une phase économique
il s'agit de rétablir ou d'établir des
liaisons routières ferroviaires en ces
temps de remettre en état ou de
construire des infrastructures et là
dessus les points 8 et 9 de l'accord du
10 novembre sont probablement assez
difficile à mettre en oeuvre
puisque on y trouve notamment la
création d'une liaison physique du
liaison terrestre entre la kitsch evans
qui est une province autonome de du 2 2
c'est une province autonome par
conséquent de l'azerbaïdjan mais qui est
séparé du reste du territoire de
l'azerbaïdjan par le territoire arménien
est l'un des acquis de l'accord du 10
novembre est en effet ne que
une route sera tracé sera construit peut
être aussi un chemin de fer qui
traversera le sud de l'arménie pour que
les deux parties de l'azerbaïdjan puisse
communiquer directement évidemment
l'arménie est inquiète de ce projet
parce que elle elle craint de perdre le
contrôle du sud de son territoire
il est prévu également dans l'accord que
ce sera la force de maintien de la paix
russes qui est ras la surveillance de ce
corridor de ce nouveau corridor comme
elle a d'ores et déjà la surveillance du
corridor de latchine qui est le cordon
ombilical qui relie l'armée ni eau ni
gaz ni karabakh ou plus exactement pour
ce territoire cette cette cité en sud
ce seront probablement les gardes
frontières du fsb qui assureront cette
tâche donc les trois participants au
sommet hier ont décidé de créer une
structure à haut niveau c'est à dire que
chacun va désigner un de ses premiers
ministres qui devront travailler créer
des sous-groupes et faire rapport sous
un mois donc très rapidement sur la
manière de créer l'infrastructure la
manière de rétablir la circulation dans
l'ensemble du pays
et tout autour du nagorny karabakh et
avec le liban ni karabakh est aussi la
manière de reprendre les échanges
économiques
c'est donc un enjeu très important mais
bien sûr la question du statut futur du
nagorny karabakh reste entière puisque
sur ce sujet qui n'a pas été évoqué
ignare pour le moment aucun accord
établir toutes ces étapes est essentiel
pour établir une paix durable dans la
région c'est ce qu'a dit aussi il a dit
mir poutine claude est ce que cette paix
durable dans la région est envisageable
selon vous oui elle et elle est
envisageable surtout que l'accord du 10
novembre est relativement complet
je crois que en effet sous la
surveillance de la force de maintien de
la paix de la russie on peut considérer
que on a maintenant un système qui est
relativement stable qui consacre
évidemment la victoire militaire de
l'azerbaïdjan sur l'arménie mais qui a
sorti un conflit gelé depuis 26 ans pour
créer une nouvelle situation dont il
faut espérer que ça ne sera pas un
nouveau conflit gelé parce que en effet
le différend sur le statut même du petit
territoire du nagorny karabakh est un
point important c'est un point important
pour l'arménie
ce petit territoire avaient déclaré
unilatéralement son indépendance
reconnue par personne pas même par
l'arménie mais évidemment l'arménie
n'acceptera pas qu'il soit purement et
simplement intégré au territoire de
l'azerbaïdjan
donc ça c'est un point important sur
lequel il va falloir continuer à
travailler et ça sera très très
difficile parce que il y a beaucoup de
souvenirs historiques
il y a beaucoup de symboles qui sont
derrière cette affaire d'un côté comme
de l'autre et puis il ya aussi l'autre
acteur qui est en coulisses à savoir la
turquie la turquie a beaucoup aidés
l'azerbaïdjan dans cette affaire par ses
conseils militaires
par ces drôles y compris les drones très
perfectionnés et elle entendait
d'ailleurs participé à la force de
maintien de la paix et la russie en
additionnés mais la turquie sera
cependant associé au centre de contrôle
de maintien de la paix c'est à dire
qu'il y aura des officiers de liaison
turc qui seront là mais pas de
militaires turcs sur le terrain par
ailleurs tous les toutes les troupes
étrangères tous les les groupes divers
et variés on avait également par le thé
parler de mercenaires syrien a mené par
les turcs ont dû se retirer et ça c'est
une demande forte de tous les partis de
tous les participants
groupe de minsk justement claude qu'en
est-il du groupe de minsk est ce qu'il
est mort écoutez je ne crois pas et je
crois qu'il est déjà des dérives mortels
enfin tant que ce conflit ne sera pas
complètement réglé pourquoi et bien
parce que dans le fond il rend un peu
service à tout le monde
la russie a besoin du raw 2011 elle fait
partie qu'elle co président avec avec la
france et avec les états unis
et on a bien vu qu'après l'accord du 10
novembre monsieur lavrov avait pris
beaucoup de soin pour informer les états
unis et la france
du contenu exact des discussions qui
avaient mené à cette à cet accord de
cessez-le-feu
c'était aussi le moyen de tenir à
distance la turquie qui souhaitaient
participer à la mise en oeuvre de
cessez-le-feu comme je viens de le dire
il ya un instant donc le groupe de minsk
introduit maintien l'organisation de la
sécurité de la coopération européenne
dans cette affaire et c'est tout à fait
son rôle bien entendu tous les pays
européens
bien sûr la russie est également la
turquie en font partie et par conséquent
la coprésidence russie etats unis france
est utile pour justement maintenant
concourir à la recherche d'une solution
durable notamment sur le statut de ce
petit territoire du haut karabagh merci
beaucoup claude pour toutes ces
précisions un claude blanchemaison
éditorialiste politique internationale
de la france